what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm inevitable we are going to watch
from his II how Captain America should
have returned the stones from my
understanding this was supposed to be
included in the actual how Avengers
endgame should have ended but because of
how long it was they were like we gotta
cut it out now it's it's own separate
video one thing I love about these guys
is oftentimes I'll be like wow that's
really funny but also great point and I
want to see if that lines up with the
great debate of how the [ __ ] they can't
in America return the stones let's check
it out
[Music]
remember you have to return the stones
it's the exact moment because of all the
branches don't work three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes wow really
you're here to close did you hear about
the Fox Disney merger
we're going to be one big happy families
sounds where's my girlfriend that's
right
you really should go to her go to her
you sexy man go to her and never look
back
[Music]
[Laughter]
shouts out okay alrighty
that would have been difficult to get
all the stones back especially like the
Power Stone
never thought about that you know
there's just so much to think about I
thought about it I thought about all
these things and they solved all the
answers right here I'm so happy they did
it but that that been John Bailey
voicing Ryan Reynolds that sounded just
like his impression of him being around
John Bailey when he does the impression
is eerie because it does sound a
thousand percent like him and I'm sure
most of these comments were like that
sounds just like Ryan Reynolds that has
to be him especially cuz he's credited
so good job John Bailey I'm just gonna
assume that was you and give you all the
credit I hope that was actually you who
did that man yeah in fact I'm gonna get
even credit for every voice in this yeah
just to be safe great job by Captain
America great job on the Hulk Red Skull
male there you nailed it this is an idea
of Captain America returning the stones
that I feel like could have been a
Disney plus one off movie or something
like that oh yeah I mean you could
actually make a pretty compelling solo
adventure and uh a lot of it doesn't
make sense when you think about certain
areas it seems like it would be a team
effort it has to be a team effort need
nebula at least he's never been to a
scar before I didn't see a scene where
they gave him a layout of how all this
works they were just pretty much like
okay here's what you got to do so yeah
Dizzy's inject it back into Jane Foster
is there gonna be some joke that said in
an upcoming movie cuz I know that Jane
Foster whatever is up some part of
different timeline according to them
because a Jane Foster's returning for
Thor love and thunder that's not good to
beat the same Jane and we saw an endgame
right not to get used to and phase four
comes out I feel like there's gonna be a
lot of multiverse
because I feel like some of this you
could explain with like a quick joke or
something like cap showed up and just
yeah it's something like that yeah
the power stone bid was a great point
because there's such a big climactic
scene that involves the power stone in
guardians of the galaxy we know the
effects of it's such a great point such
a great point I love the little
band-aids all over the tesseract and I
think my favorite one is the Red Skull
and the soul stone and the whole like
we're so late to the game I was just so
dazzling what everyone's been talking
about I thought the least about because
it was so late to the thought game I
know I saw the movie and I was like oh
good this is the end of a chapter I can
stop thinking so many movie news sites
and Twitter does it constantly how do
you return - it wasn't what that
confrontation with red skull was like it
was probably actually really nice
because the red skulls probably gained a
lot of perspective over time I mean he's
alone almost disembodied the way he like
floats around now so you know maybe he's
really Zen what I would like to see his
he pull off one day you know how Family
Guy has their Peter Griffin and chicken
fight it's funny because of how long it
is and just how detailed it is and how
it's grown over time but it's so cool at
the same time like it's a really cool
fight and sometimes Family Guy breaks
that it's really cool action scenes and
I feel like it'd be really cool if one
day they did something like a really
epic badass tonight yeah just like an
animation fiesta a combat they had
Captain America a Red Skull and go ahead
like the old Deadpool bits really funny
but it would also have been cool oh we
actually get some showdown between Red
Skull who's like I don't know how he
eats or what is he Red Skull we better
explain that one day besides what the
hell is a Red Skull I don't understand
how he's alive why is he floating well
he doesn't look like he's fully alive
he's not human
yeah he looks like some kind of spirit
who's trapped yeah soul stone realm but
he still have a grudge against Captain
America damn fin Utley he's still petty
yeah I would've liked to have seen that
conflict go down keep the jokes in the
humor alive but I think do his nowhere
who could have been
that's interesting take that property
could it happen that's why I let me to
think this would be a cool Disney Plus
show what it makes sense for the what
ifs but you could be like what if we saw
it happen and that is our animated movie
make it happen they could do you know
what if or not what if but how did
Doctor Strange assemble everyone mm-hmm
at the end of it or they all come back
and they're just like this guy every bit
who's this guy yeah y-you see all the
different people he didn't get to show
I'm right you know somebody didn't sure
sure yeah well guys you can subscribe to
how it should have been and if you
haven't done so already what's your
favorite how it should have ended video
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification mel and let's give a
patient the day shout out to a man named
Taylor Bentley Taylor I have nothing
left to offer you in these shout outs
not uh you are pledged thank you I love
the support clearly we like to customize
and personalize the [ __ ] out of these
shout outs you won't get back to me I
don't know what happened
alright your girlfriend have you chained
somewhere is she afraid you're gonna
have like go online and just watch
nothing but pornography so you're not
allowed to access the patreon page
imagine they live like a mercy type of
you know lifestyle what the hell is
mercy job where you talk to Kathy Bates
and James on misery misery how did you
ever do good in that understand you know
I had an earpiece and I was being fed
the answers the entire time Taylor I
don't know why you won't reply back just
yeah keep your card on file you know you
know the drill Cuba kind of huh I don't
know your girlfriend she's probably an
emotionally abusive woman and that's the
most I could conclude why you haven't
gotten back only possible explanation or
or she broke up with you recently and
you're depressed you're depressed and
you don't want to talk about us and you
want to be forced to laugh while you're
feeling that bottom line I'm blaming the
woman for why you haven't gotten back to
me that's a good strategy especially in
this day and age